despite a nationwide push for police
reform Republicans and Democrats remain
divided on the best way to enact change
in 2017 the Trump administration under
then Attorney General Jeff Sessions
drastically changed a program designed
to bring more transparency to troubled
Police Department's CBS News senior
investigative correspondent Catherine
Herridge shows us how the changes left
some communities feeling abandoned
Catherine good morning well Anthony good
morning the Obama administration
launched the program to help bring
together local communities and their
police departments on a voluntary basis
to tackle issues like use of force and
racial bias and when the Justice
Department overhauled the program three
years ago it left one town fighting for
data and prompted a lawsuit captured on
video the 2015 fatal shooting of 50
year-old Walter Scott an unarmed black
man in North Charleston South Carolina
was the community's breaking point
Michael Slager the officer who shot
Scott was later sentenced to 20 years
for violating his civil rights grace be
shown for the community Thomas Dixon is
a local pastor the evidence from the
community the reports from the community
were long-standing vigils and protests
followed as grief gave way to hope that
a new approach was imminent today we're
here to formally announce a year after
Scott's death
local officials and the Justice
Department launched a collaborative
review of the North Charleston Police
the voluntary process in which the North
Charleston Police Department agreed to
participate involved compiling a report
that report would be released to the
public along with recommendations for
reform the department Vanita Gupta ran
the Obama administration's Civil Rights
Division most Americans have not heard
of the collaborative reform initiatives
why does it matter it would have been
another tool that the Justice Department
had to work with communities and local
leadership but in 2017 then Attorney
General Jeff Sessions
overhauled the program ending the
assessment process and the release of
public reports a Department of Justice
spokesperson says the program
modifications were made to ensure that
resources go to agencies that require
assistance
rather than expensive wide-ranging
investigative assessments CBS News found
at least 13 jurisdictions were impacted
by the changes including North
Charleston this administration basically
undid the program and left these
jurisdictions in the lurch that year
North Charleston residents called on the
Justice Department to be transparent
release that report now not yesterday
now the state's Republican senator Tim
Scott also urged officials to release
any final or near final findings and
recommendations but that never happened
it was really more niek Dixon is the
deputy director of policy at the
n-double-a-cp
Legal Defense Fund essentially told
black and brown communities that the
n-double-a-cp Legal Defense Fund is
suing the Justice Department for a copy
of the report after an official request
yielded this document almost entirely
blacked out earlier this year another
violent episode was captured on video in
a North Charleston Hotel that incident
is not isolated five years after Walter
Scott it's it's not isolated and it's
because the information that could have
got the skeletons out of the closet were
contained in that DOJ investigation to
abdicate the use of this tool I think
has really underserved the American
public and at a time where so many
people are clamoring for change
Justice Department spokesperson tells
CBS News the issue is not under
consideration because they say the draft
reports contain unsubstantiated
information in North Charleston city
officials recently authorized a racial
bias audit of the police department Tony
and so that fight for transparency
continues Catherine thank you very much